who let them do this
how is this allowed
why are the subtitles one of the
strangest things in stranger things
in this video we're going to look at the
10 strangest things from netflix's hit
series stranger things and i don't mean
things like demogorgons or alternate
dimensions i mean things like the
subtitles
also stick around to the end for what
i'd say is the absolute strangest thing
from all four seasons of stranger things
[Music]
as i mentioned before the subtitles for
the series are absolutely bonkers
especially in season 4 of the show one
of netflix's employees on their
subtitling team carly webster explained
we have complete free reign as far as
i'm aware i don't think there was
anything that we were told we couldn't
add as far as production being involved
and telling us how far we can take it
that didn't happen they put a lot of
thought and effort into subtitling each
episode and the team did a great job of
explaining the show's sounds more
accurately than any other show i've seen
before they went to great lengths to
make sure anyone who is deaf or hard of
hearing would be able to enjoy the show
to the same extent as anyone else and
they were spot on with every line up
next is will's haircut it went from okay
to bad to worse to absolutely terrible
the actor who plays will buyers noah
schnapp apparently begged the show's
creators the duffer brothers to let him
have a different haircut for season 4
but they insisted that it was of the
times noah even joked that he plans on
making a powerpoint presentation as to
why he shouldn't have to have the bolt
cut in season 5 of the show so we'll
have to wait and see if its presentation
pans out like he wants
next up is the fact that in season 1
hopper turned 11 over to the authorities
and now they have such a close
relationship that it seems impossible he
would ever have been able to do such a
thing as part of an agreement he made
with the folks at hawkins laboratory
hopper agreed to give up 11's location
to save will although the kids were fine
in the end it's crazy to think he was
willing to give her up at one point and
now he would do anything to help her
even going so far as to break back into
a russian prison to fight a demogorgon
to potentially give her the upper hand
in fighting a greater threat in the
upside down definitely a complete 180 in
their relationship but we can't imagine
it any other way the next strangest
thing in the series takes place in
season 4 when will cries in the car
right next to mike and he doesn't seem
to notice at all i get that teenagers
can be oblivious but if someone is
sitting mere inches away from you
bawling their eyes out it should be
pretty easy to tell
i get that mike's thinking only about 11
in the moment but you'd think he'd speak
up and ask if will's okay i guess the
haircut must have distracted him too
much or something next up one of the
strangest things about the show lies in
the question of how a sci-fi 80s series
became one of the most popular tv shows
in entertainment history before stranger
things retro tv shows and sci-fi netflix
originals only appealed to a very small
audience but now stranger things has
become one of the most watched series of
all time on the platform and it's given
somewhat of a rebirth to 80s fashion
dungeons and dragons and even music from
the 80s for example kate bush's running
up that hill was a pretty popular song
in the 80s but since stranger things
season 4 was released spotify streams
for the song have gone up by over nine
thousand percent in the united states
and it's hit the top ten billboards for
both the us and the uk it's just crazy
that a sci-fi tv show about kids playing
dungeons and dragons could make such an
impact on the entertainment industry in
such a short period of time another
strange thing about the series is that
we're willing to sit through
movie-length episodes when typically
people hardly have the patience to sit
through a 20 minute sitcom while big
budget movie run times have seemingly
grown longer in recent years stranger
things lengthening of episodes is the
first popular instance of this happening
in the tv series medium i think it's
likely we'll begin to see other popular
shows release longer and longer episodes
as people become more willing to binge
for longer and longer especially on
shows with already well-established
casts and settings looking at you rings
of power next up is the fact that nancy
wheeler is pretty good with guns with
little to no guidance or training nancy
seems to be able to pick up almost any
firearm and use it perfectly she's
almost like a trained demogorgon
assassin capable of loading and firing
any gun she can get her hands on i
understand that she could have had some
sort of firearm training off-screen but
i think it's just so strange that they
went with her character for the
gunslinger either way it still works
really well the next strangest thing
about the series is from season one
again when the police found will's fake
body in the lake apparently the duffer
brothers thought a fake body would look
too well fake so they asked a 30 year
old woman to stand in or lie in for the
dummy body for several shots in the
first season we asked a stunt woman to
go into that icy 3am water as will
buyers so that it would look maximum
convincing said producer sean levy and i
have to say it did look pretty
convincing on the first watch the
runner-up for the strangest things in
stranger things is the fact that steve
harrington was supposed to die in season
one in the original story steve was
supposed to have died pretty early on
and jonathan's dad was supposed to be
the one who fought the demogorgon in the
end upon seeing joe kiri's acting in the
role though the duffer brothers decided
to rewrite the story and keep him around
seeing the show where it is now it's
almost impossible to imagine the gang
getting together without steve kiri has
done a fantastic job of playing the
mother henry over the younger actors and
he's also played a key role in the love
triangle with jonathan and nancy i mean
without him we wouldn't have this
[Laughter]
now the strangest thing of all in the
series has to be the fact that in every
season a new beloved character is always
killed off whether it be barbara in
season 1 bob in season 2 alexi in season
3 or chrissy and eddie in season 4 our
new favorite characters always seem to
die it's almost gotten to the point
where when we see a new character we
like each season we can almost guarantee
that they'll be dead by the end of it
very few new and likable characters have
made it past their debut season such as
dr owens and robin
this has to be one of the strangest
things about the show because it seems
all of these super likable characters
have their potential wasted in just a
matter of episodes honorable mentions
for new characters that died include max
who died but then came back to life kind
of like hopper jason and billy now this
is certainly not an all exhaustive list
of the strangest things in stranger
things so i'd like to see what you think
drop your favorite things from the
series in the comment section below also
maybe think about checking out the video
on your screen for some more of my
content don't forget to like and
subscribe and thanks for watching rocket
riley
you